in laboratories like this all over the
world scientists are trying to answer
the same questions how can Co vat19 be
stopped is there a cure when will this
global crisis be over at the Pasteur
Institute in Tehran Iranian experts are
working with Chinese colleagues to try
and improve testing for the virus
something that has been a challenge
since the early days of the outbreak I'm
coming here for just habit and training
and how to test because now it's all
products here for the testing our
interview with the visiting expert was
cut short by security the government
here has been criticized for responding
too slowly to the pandemic and it seems
officials in Tehran remain sensitive
about anything related to its
coronavirus response set up in 1920 the
campus in Tehran is named for French
scientist Louis Pasteur a 19th century
pioneer of modern medicine this
Institute runs dozens of labs and
employs hundreds of staff across the
country the government hopes research
and development here will enable Iran to
export diagnostic kits and medical
equipment
this facility is nearly a hundred years
old and one of the largest of its kind
in the Middle East for years scientists
and these kinds of labs have been
fighting all manner of diseases
infectious diseases and now their
priority the inescapable priority for
these men and women is to try to find a
way to fight Kovach 19 why is the virus
more severe in some patients
does it mutate and can survivors develop
immunity answers to these questions and
the discovery of a vaccine in a place
named after a pioneer in the field would
be an outstanding achievement and the
head of the Institute made it clear that
is the ambition we are working on
producing the technical knowledge for a
vaccine and focusing on medicine and
treatment to see which medicine could be
a good candidate for curing the disease
but on the day of our visit Iran's
president was more guarded in an address
to his cabinet Hassan rouhani was clear
there have been no breakthroughs social
distancing is the best policy
and everyone's in this for the long haul
Amedeo name banner bar faced on the
assumption that this virus will
unfortunately remain with people for
some time and nobody in the world can
predict when this epidemic will end days
weeks or months we have to observe
health protocols while continuing work
production and activities it comes to
kroehner people have the major role
there is no treatment no medication or
vaccine for it
so the fundamental thing is to be
careful about ourselves while finding a
cure is the end goal testing is also
important last month the Revolutionary
Guards unveiled a handheld device they
said was capable of detecting an
infected person from a hundred meters
away but its effectiveness was
criticized and Iran's Health Ministry
did not approve it for use with no easy
fixes scientists carry on with their
research how to end the pandemic remains
an open question and they intend to find
the answer
Zane Basra via al Jazeera Tehran